with its emphasis on aggression violence
and loud music the racist skinhead
subculture can be attractive to young
men alright next thing we're to break
into your partner for this we're going
to work on securing a basic boy time
flinch and throwing needs this is real
devastating for either in the rain or in
the street especially devastating in the
street I come in based in Baltimore
the Maryland skinheads RMDs preach
loyalty to one's brothers in the group
and devotion to the white race
membership requires conforming to the
group's Commandments including those
about accepting the skinheads warrior
role
Jason Tankersley leads the statewide
organization physical fitness the
ability to defend yourself it's all
terribly important to us it's constant
self-improvement these are men
especially young men who feel like the
old John Wayne notion of masculinity has
been taken away it's been taken away by
feminism by liberalism by people who are
taking away their manufacturing jobs
just usually seen as some type of Jewish
conspiracy so they're reclaiming it the
best way that they can conceptualize
which is through this intense violent
culture Tankersley will not disclose
exact membership numbers but says his
crew has more than tripled since it
began and continues to grow Tankersley
is cautious about who joins the club I
look for you know basic physical
conditioning they have to be a tough
individual because that is the type of
club we are again we're not just a
political organization so that's very
important and also you know sacrifice
they have to show that they're willing
to sacrifice for the club the men attend
regular training sessions and wait a
year before becoming full-fledged
members Tankersley uses this time to
weed out prospects who aren't truly
dedicated to the cause we're back wide
down
today a recruit named Chris finally
becomes a member
guys hard as nails he's done everything
we asked him to do so now today we're
gonna play Apache man make him a full
member in the MDS Chris you'd like to
come on up here all right brother we're
go ahead and give you this patch
sometimes you to full membership in the
MTS you've done everything to earn it
you've been a great brother and done
absolutely everything we come 1
congratulate as a brother Chris is
expected to support all group activities
and most importantly help increase
membership I should be able to take
anyone from the club put them into an
area of the state where no one's living
where there's no skin as where there's
no activity center etc and within six
months to a year they should have a
small club started there